nos dicen que bebe 1 es igual a 7
negativo y bdn es igual a bdn 112 y nos
piden encontrar el cuarto término en la
secuencia lo que tenemos aquí que
podríamos usar para definir una función
en realidad está definiendo los términos
de una secuencia especialmente si se
introducen números enteros aquí que es
el índice de la secuencia lo que
realmente queremos hacer es descubrir
cuánto es verde 4 bueno si aplicamos
esto directamente podríamos decir que ve
de 4 si bbn es bdn menos 112 entonces va
a ser de 4 menos uno más 12 y 4 menos
uno es igual a tres así que esto es
igual a b de 3 más 12 no estoy tratando
de descubrir inmediatamente cuánto es b
de 1 estoy tratando de resolver cuánto
es de 4 así que en es igual a 4 entonces
veré 4 es igual a b de 4 menos uno que
es 3 más 12 y para evaluar esto tenemos
que saber cuánto es b de 3
así que escribamos lo esto es lo
divertido de las definiciones recursivas
tienes que regresar recursiva mente ve
de 3 tiene es igual a 3 esto va a ser
igual a bdn menos 1 que estos más 12
pero no sabemos cuánto es b de 2 así que
tenemos que continuar y bd todos usamos
la misma definición b de todos es igual
a b de 2 - 1 + 12 entonces pd 2 menos
uno es igual a b de uno más 12 pero no
sabemos cuánto es b de 1 así que vamos a
resolverlo b b1 es igual bueno
finalmente podemos usar la cláusula que
tenemos aquí arriba b b1 es igual a
menos 7 ahora podemos continuar y
resolver todo de regreso si vd 1 es
igual a 7 negativo entonces sabemos que
esto que tenemos aquí es igual a 7
negativo y podemos resolver
pd2 que es menos 7 más 12 igual a 5 si
ve de 2 es igual a 5 entonces esto es
igual a 5
vamos a ver a que es igual ve de 3 que
es igual a 5 12 lo que es igual a 17 y
si sabemos que ve de 3 es igual a 17 ya
podemos calcular 24 v de 4 ahora es
igual a b de 3 que vale 17 más 12 lo que
es igual a 29 y terminamos